student loan debt i'm going to read
these stories and you tell me your
thoughts on the student loan debt that
we got going on the forgiveness program
that we have going on
um let's see which story okay so former
clinton advisor slams biden student loan
debt handout this is terrible
policy
well it's bad policy as well as bad
politics for that amount of money you
could find free uh pre-k
for every three and four-year-old for 10
years you can do a lot more good for
poor people
communities of color and underprivileged
by doing pre-k you could forgive all
medical debt which unlike student debt
is not free enter freely entered into
former advisor to clinton said paula
begla said that
said adding that he was a progressive
what is my party doing with this they're
disadvantaging
i think they're not helping the people
we're here to help which is poor people
underprivileged communities and they're
not helping their politicians who are
running
uh begala said this so at the same time
bernie sanders i'll give you what bernie
said about this
bernie said uh uh on sunday responded to
examples of democrat criticizing
uh half a trillion dollar student loan
that hand that by saying the criticism
is correct before arguing that the
answer is not to deny help to people who
cannot deal with these
uh horrendous student debt maybe we
should have the courage to take on the
drug companies and not pay ten times
more for a particular drug than they do
in other countries so the answer is not
to do what republicans want to do oh
it's unfair to this person because we're
helping that person the answer is maybe
to create government which works for all
people and not just the wealthy campaign
contributors that's what bernie sanders
had to say tom what are your thoughts on
this student debt forgiveness well i'll
tell you i don't normally line up
the way i line up right now with paul
begela but i am a hundred percent with
him there are upstream problems in this
country and there are downstream
problems
the student debt that is in the hands of
these students that are being really
hammered by the processors remember it's
the loan processors
once you get the student loan debt you
get a letter from somebody that say hi
we are the company that's going to be
processing your debt send your payments
here and the interest rates and
everything that go with that the
students get hammered by that that's
downstream if you want to go back
upstream paul begela is doing a great
job of making a point is saying listen
want to help education when you get
people more educated we could take all
this and we could cover pre-k and three
or four-year-olds so we could start
education an earlier year and give kids
that are normally disadvantaged a jump
start maybe
to be
you know more competitive later i love
that line but the other side of it that
that i'm looking at is bernie is right
what they're doing here is forgiving the
people who knowingly went into the debt
now i happen to think
what we should probably be doing
is working on a relief with the
processors what if we took one tenth of
that half a trillion dollars and bought
down the interest rate with the
processors so that people have a
fighting chance to pay off the debt says
hey you owe 80 000 to the processor
currently it's sitting at nine and a
half wham it's four now it's four
percent you know as well as i do adam
just the
this the math of money that would be a
huge help on the interest rate side of
things that's exactly right so rather
than forgiving the debt why don't we get
into it and say how do we make it more
manageable for these people to pay off
and something else i'd love to talk
about pbd on another time
if the oil companies raise prices and
they get drug into congress for price
gouging hearings
guess what the entire
collegiate system needs to be dragged in
front of congress for price gouging
hearings yeah so
my angle is a different angle by the way
and i i appreciate that tyler can you
show the video i just sent you i don't
know if you have it or not so this is a
father going up to elizabeth warren do
we comment on this yet or not i have no
idea okay so so elizabeth warren's
talking a bunch of folks
and his father on the day when they
announced this walks up to elizabeth
warren and says this and she has nothing
to say like elizabeth warren's helper
cannot wait for this man to stop talking
you'll see this if you can make it
bigger so everybody can see it go ahead
and play it and let's see let's hear the
audio watch this and then she says
something
oh
fast forward a little bit like three
seconds but he's waiting for it okay
right there watch this yep this guy in
the blackjack listen
my daughter's getting out of school i've
saved all my money she doesn't have any
students
am i gonna get my money back
so you're gonna pay for people who
didn't save any money and those of us
who did the right thing get screwed
of course we did it my buddy had fun
bought a car went on vacations i saved
my money
he made more than i did but i worked a
double shift worked extra like dollars
works he was 10. so you're laughing
yeah that's exactly what you're doing we
did the right thing and we get screwed i
appreciate it
yeah
i love those moments so so you know so
you can't blame people like that who are
sitting there saying i did all the right
thing but you're going this direction
and then what i will say kind of where
tom was briefly commenting on it is the
following thing here's what we have to
ask ourselves okay
so in the process in in this
context of student loan what parties are
involved let's go through it number one
is the loaner the loaner is who sallie
mae sally made number the end number two
is who is the person that's receiving
the debt which is who the individual
customer student the customer student
possibly which parents right
okay so we got the loaner which is sally
may and
navient okay then we have the person
that's getting the loan which is the
student
hence the parent then we have government
and then we have college okay so you
have four parties involved here now
let's take a look at this when they do
this
who doesn't pay a single price for this
by the way we have one other person
involved in this as well it's called
taxpayers okay yeah so we got taxpayers
which is us we got the student that got
the loan we got the sallie mae who was
like [ __ ] here you go and then we have
the government and then we have the
university who paid the least price when
this decision was made exactly
exactly and you know what you know
what's crazy about that this part that's
crazy about that when you're talking
about universities
universities
themselves you know are sitting there
uh they keep the money and 80 they said
the other day for every one conservative
uh professor in america there's 13
liberal professors in america so they
have a monopoly on philosophies they're
teaching to our students that are being
sent there so there is already a
monopoly of teaching a philosophy that
you have a control over you're not
getting a
six professors on one side six on
another side or six six and one
independent and you're kind of learning
from everybody and then on top of that
part that we're talking about with
schooling
they have the audacity to bash
capitalists who pay taxes
who go through what they go through and
you're not paying any taxes
and at the same time you're not even
being punished the punishment's going on
students no one's judging you for your
quality of education where salaries
haven't increased for the last 20 years
maybe you ought to be judged a little
bit if education is so fantastic about
how how are kids coming out with the
same average salary as they got 20 years
ago you want to blame corporations how
about we blame your method of education
how come we can't hold them accountable
how come nobody can get at them and say
hey no no no you can't talk about this
because i went to such-and-such school
and i'm a booster god forbid we say
anything about this university so that
part is not being accountable so then go
to the next one and let's find out who
pays the biggest price so the person
that pays the least price and this party
is who university university who pays
the biggest price
the tax the customer the customer which
is the student the parents yeah their
parents who's the second that pays the
biggest price
taxpayer it's us it's us okay because
we're backstop when you forgive it you
got it so there's two left government
and salami which lets you say it's the
least they're there so the person that
pays the biggest price is the student
second is us the taxpayer least is
colleges then it's sallie mae and the
government what are we talking about and
it's not what we're talking about here
it's not to feel bad about but there is
a party in this the loan processors who
are now going to be processing less
loans so they're going to make less
money so as a business the loan
processors are going to have their
business hit look
it's hard to feel bad for those
particular folks the biggest question is
the following question okay
what can you and i go
and get financing from the bank
for like house call okay so we can get a
house the bank will bank uh uh finance
uh will uh uh a house house a car will
they finance a car of course will they
finance a wedding no no why not
because there's no terrorist it's going
to fail
way too much
so they will not finance a wedding okay
let's keep going with this will they
finance me
uh potentially starting a business maybe
at best you're right maybe at best well
but only to the extent you'll sign a
personal guarantee against your outset
if you even have that motorcycle
motorcycle i got a motorcycle how about
an art piece of art if i'm getting will
they finance a piece of art i don't
think so
the bigger banks goldman morgan they
will do it i don't know if the bank of
america guy hey kpbs can you find this
trying to buy the salmon monday whatever
but it's usually half value
but she's like half value yeah now
here's the last one you're ready
how many banks finance me to go get a
four-year college zero why not that one
weird why are we the fed so bank at the
same time let me get this straight banks
won't finance weddings
college
yeah way too risky yeah all right
maybe there is a lesson there because
what capitalism and free enterprise will
teach us is whatever people are not
willing to pay for there's a reason for
it okay there's a reason for it what are
your thoughts with this story here well
look um there's sort of mixed
i have mixed kind of feelings here i'm
not a fan of this believe me the guy
that went up to elizabeth warren here
who said i saved that money you're never
going to hear me disagree with that yeah
100 okay that is my entire slogan of my
entire life is save that money so
respect to that guy double shift exactly
so but there is a difference between the
elizabeth warren bernie sanders wing of
the
progressive left and the
biden side of things because they all
campaigned on different promises so
everyone was talking about promises made
promises kept
biden campaigned on cancelling ten
thousand dollars of student loan debt
whether you agree with that or disagree
with them that's a different topic
that's what he campaigned on elizabeth
warren and bernie wanted to cancel all
debt and everyone was like yeah that's a
little freaking aggressive bro so
there's 20 million americans who woke up
this week and said i owe exactly zero
dollars now if you're that person the
choice is yours now buddy you've been
given a life raft you somehow woke up
you had twenty thousand dollars of
student loan debt depending on your uh
pell grant status right tom the pell
grant yeah that's if you're a lower
income the whole mechanism and
and i think 40 americans have
received some sort of loan forgiveness
so
i'm not a fan of this i had d1 on my
show the sauce cast last week this guy
got famous viral for doing a song called
i paid sally maybach where it was a play
on words between rather than driving a
maybach because he's a rapper he paid
sally maybe that's actually pretty dope
and it was ridiculous it went viral and
the guy hit the scene so i'm not a fan
of this but this is what biden uh did
promise
my next point and then i'll turn it back
over to you guys
the fact that paul
my like how my whole save that money
political uh wokeness whatever you
wanted like awakening
it actually happened at a um insurance
event that you've ever been to aalu i
know what it is okay but you we've met
it now about years ago and alu and now
back actually merged it's an area called
finseca now right
and this is
2010 2012-ish
and they had a debate you talk about
this is your idea of what you want
school to look like they had a debate
and who was the debate with paul bagala
clinton guy and none other than
tucker carlson
fox guy so i'm sitting there listening i
have no political ideology at this point
i'm just watching tucker and paul pagala
go at it i'm like i like this [ __ ] yeah
this is good i ideology's exchanged left
right up down i'm like okay he's got a
point he's got a point he's got a point
but circling back making my point here
this is something that tucker and paul
pagala would both agree on they do they
they do not like this idea yeah all this
time i'm pissed off because i mean we
both joined the military about the same
age now i'm pissed off because i didn't
go to college i didn't spend no now i'm
just like what now i have to pay for
other people's kids to [ __ ] go to
college and it drives me bananas so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]